[Music]
who's the sexiest man alive not
including one who co-hosts the five
paul rudd wins the award and i need to
know how this contest was scored
people magazine the number one magazine
for cannibals
people
name the actor uh the 2021 sexiest man
alive as for sexist man dead for the
97th year in a row vladimir lenin
look
has not changed a bit
so i didn't win again
i guess they must have accidentally
tossed out my application with the bed
bath and beyond coupons
paul told people he's gonna lean into it
hard hate that cliche joking that he'll
have business cards made a joke that
showed how old this sexiest man is what
is a business card but he also said that
so many other people should have been
named sexiest man alive before him and
we couldn't agree more in fact here are
our top picks for sexiest man alive
[Music]
greg's sexiest man alive
is it stuart barney
how about steve ducey
or maybe
[Music]
could it be bill hammer
no
it's harold ford jr oh yeah
take that paul rudd
very nice
let's say you we we should all admit
that harold ford is too good looking for
fox
no no no no shouldn't hit that at all
all right
i'm talking about dudes not women you
can admit it yes
susan uh woody how do you feel about the
choice
how do you feel about the choice well so
do you remember clueless of course he
was great at that yeah he's you know he
hasn't really aged that much but okay so
what's in his 50s now i know but what
i'm trying to say is that why isn't
there a sexiest woman alive in her 50s
ooh that's what i love to see that i
have i have a few nominees like j.lo
jennifer aniston she's 50. the judge the
judge
yeah she's got some arms right
speaking of uh well the judge uh you did
not know who paul rudd is that's okay
no i recognize his face but he's you
know it's like it's nothing he doesn't
make you hot right no not at all who
would be your uh choice harold ford jr
uh
could i pick someone who's in the acting
yes sure okay harold ford jr
[Laughter]
he's quite he's quite the church quite
the charmer yeah he's also over 50.
works for me yeah
um loftus you were you were actually
named uh sexiest homeless man
i want to congratulate you on that
um
you're happy yeah pretty happy yeah that
one yes
we're gonna have a party later yeah down
by the tracks yeah you're gonna light a
fire in that garbage can there's gonna
be harmonica playing
our belongings on sticks just walking
down yeah it's gonna be good until one
of you gets too drunk and and murders
somebody who gets too chatty
don't look at joe now
his mom used to boil coca-cola and he'd
just feed it to him with ginger this is
no this is the end of times this is the
end of times he's a great guy he's a
talented actor all that stuff he's not
the sexiest man alive he's not non-by
the way he's not non-binary where are
the pregnant men
this might be the last one of these we
ever get yes because people are going to
get upset it's just going to be the
sexiest thing that identifies as a thing
yes you know and if you i says i don't
think anybody does any lady really are
you thinking about paul rudd at night
are you waking up like wow i just had a
paul rudd dream again
it doesn't happen i don't think paul
rudd's wife has paul rudd dreams
that was well no one has well anyway
[Laughter]
cat nobody has celebrity dreams anyway
right people like people around them
isn't that how it goes like you know
harold ford jr okay
i think that i think that he maybe he'll
watch yeah
yeah he's good paul rhode is
good-looking but he's not hot
like he's not sexy right right there's a
difference and i knew that even like
when i was little oh really yeah yes
like when you're little and you have
celebrity crushes when i was little mine
were um kurt cobain steve eiserman from
the red wings and dennis rodman right
none of those people are the same
because it does it's not about physical
he's not hot no no good looking does not
mean hot
there i don't know if i can tell if
someone's hot or not though
no but there's zero danger to that guy
what happened to like the dangerous dude
he looks like everyone who's hot there
has to be an element of a little danger
yeah
harold ford jr seems dangerous right
to me
no
maybe you can just call him no i'm just
saying he's you know he's not on the
list it's kind of unfair we kind of need
some big biceps you know like chris
hemsworth oh no oh there's the guy
don't you agree
uh-oh yeah we touched the thor buck yeah
yes we did
you're right
is that what they're calling looks like
you would ignore me for the gym yeah and
you know what i mean didn't he play
james hunt in rush
yeah yeah yeah nicely done look at you
once look at you yeah all right we gotta
you know
you know hemsworth we got it real good
we got a topic that goes even in worse
into this topic
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else